two Sundays ago we're at the house and
I'm sitting there saying Mario is asking
questions we're going back and forth
it's like so you know how do you do
leadership development how do you
improve yourself how do you increase the
value of the marketplace what do we do
with some of our guys what do you do to
get your people to be better and
yourself to get better and we wrote out
and we came out with this Paradigm Shift
quadrant let me share this with you
there's four areas
that you and I can improve ourselves to
increase our market value
two of them you do doesn't explode your
market value two above that you do
explodes your market value you and the
people that work with you let me share
this with you bottom left is hard skills
does anybody here have a hard skill that
pays very well raise your hand if you
have a good hard skill matter of fact on
three scream out the hard skill that
you're very good at one two three
that's a hard skill okay
so first one is hard skills you'll learn
how to get a hard skills if you learn
hard skills you pretty much have a nice
salary for yourself but it's not enough
so what's the next one Pat I said
character
what's character character doesn't mean
stealing cheating any of that stuff
character to me is somebody that shows
up somebody that's doing the work
somebody if they say they're going to do
something they do somebody that follows
up somebody that doesn't cancel
appointments if we got a five o'clock
appointment all of a sudden somebody
invites you to a Laker game you don't
cancel the appointment go to a Laker
game and reschedule it there's a lot of
sales people that will always reschedule
appointments the moment something else
comes up I don't like that kind of stuff
you got a four o'clock appointment keep
your four o'clock appointment unless if
a massive crisis happens and less than
one percent of your appointment you
should reschedule or cancel let me say
that one more time less than one percent
of your appointments you should ever
reschedule and cancel this guy keeps all
of his appointments he shows up on time
clients are very happy
if you do those two things is that
enough
are those two things alone to increase
your market value today
the answer is no because those two just
make you a good citizen
and every company every Community every
society needs good citizens but it's not
enough there's two of them that we got
to go through here soft skills today
is very very valuable a lot of people
are not that good at soft skills a lot
of people know how to do real estate
maybe they know how to sell but they're
not that good with people they know how
to do insurance annuities 401ks but
they're not that good with people soft
skill is known how to talk to a person
that's a customer that's married
during their 60s you talk to somebody
that's widowed divorced white black
Hispanic Asian degree no degree makes
six figures as low income middle income
very wealthy very well off affluent soft
skills allows that person to be able to
work with everyone you increase your
market value if you got good soft skills
and then the last one is a paradigm
shift
almost everybody in this room if you
ever suddenly recreated yourself and you
were a new person that your family
friends had never seen before you had a
paradigm shift
you had a paradigm shift it could have
been with your family it could have been
with your friends it could have been
with something but let me explain what a
paradigm shift is
paradigm shift is some of you guys are
here is this day one or is this day two
of the event this is day two
they wanted the event okay
who today out of all the speakers not
myself the people Prime me who today
said something to you that got you
really thinking all day today
how many guys saw something somebody
said that you've been thinking about it
all day today
okay so what was it somebody tell me
what it was what was the one thing
somebody told you that got you thinking
all day today
mental toughness what else is it
execute what else
operations and systems what else
say that again
long term what else
total Recreation okay let me give you
some Paradigm shifts for me
I'm in the Army
I'm about to re-enlist for six years
it's June of 1999. everything I asked
for my sergeant they brought for me my
Colonel they gave to me I'm going to
Vicenza Italy
I'm going to go be a special forces 18
Delta they gave me everything I spoke
four languages five languages German was
good but it wasn't good enough to be
counted as a fifth I was gonna go to DLI
I was going to go to the chance I was
going to get everything
I'm in bed at 11 45 I get a call from a
guy I had barbecued last night guy's
name is coken he calls me says hey Pat
how's everything I said great I'm about
to re-enlist for six more years they got
me everything I wanted he says what do
you mean I said I'm about to stay in the
Army for six more years he says you
can't do that I said what do you mean I
can't do that I'm doing that I'm doing
it tomorrow you can't do that
I said I'm doing it tomorrow like I
can't do anything about I already told
my dad I'm re-enlisting tomorrow it's my
ceremony I'm getting an army
accommodation medal and I'm gone Pat you
can't do it give me one hour to convince
you not to do it I'm like you're not
going to do it one hour on the phone
the things he told me
he shook me
I couldn't believe what he was telling
me by the time we were done I couldn't
sleep all night I woke up I couldn't
even sleep I got up in the morning I
went to Lieutenant Colonel peacocks
as a colonel peacocks I got to tell you
something he says what's that
I said I can't reenlist
he says what do you mean he said I got
to go into civilian I got to go be a
civilian I think I can make it as a
civilian but David you're going to be an
incredible Soldier for us I can't bring
a list I have to get out I got a phone
call I'm so sorry because you changed my
life I got to get out I can't reenlist
they pull my Army accommodation medal I
get out of the army that phone call was
a paradigm shift because the guy made a
phone call and believed in me at my
lower like I'm like me I'm a regular
army guy 1.8 GPA who was in the military
here before Make Some Noise if you were
in the military before okay let's make
some noise for these guys by the way
what was your what was your ASVAB score
scream out your ASVAB score on three one
two three
I I got a 31.
the only job I could be is infantry or a
Hummer mechanic guess what I chose
Hummer mechanic
I'm a regular guy I'm supposed to do 20
years in the military that phone call
shook me couldn't sleep I had a paradigm
shift I got out my life changed
one day I'm at a Christmas party with my
family my dad and I a Syrian Christmas
party I'm 25 26 years old
we're talking to everybody we're poor
we're not doing well
and one of the guys on my dad changed
his life the guy makes a comment to my
my dad offends my dad
I listened to him I'm like
dad what did he just say to you he said
this I see you can't talk to you like
that I said Patrick these are my friends
you can't say anything I said no we're
leaving we're not staying here right now
we got to get out of here I said no no
we're not leaving it's a Christmas party
they invited I said that way you don't
talk to my dad like this I said listen I
love you your family I love you a lot
but you don't talk like that it's just a
joke it's not a joke I like
it's not a joke I like that we're
leaving I'm not leaving with you I'm
your I'm your ride what are you talking
let's go look we gotta well I'm not
leaving with you what's the matter I
said we're leaving Dad we're leaving
we get in the car Ford Focus is what I'm
doing I'm six five I don't fit on the
Ford Focus I'm driving a Ford Focus
do you know 30 minute drive from
Glendale to Granada Hills were fighting
the entire time
we're fighting I'm like I allowed
another man to disrespect my dad in
front of me and I'm not
guys that small little
75 second interaction is why I told my
entire family the World's Gonna know my
dad's last name
I said dad they're gonna have to kill
this guy they're gonna know your last
name
they're going to know your last name how
much you did for all of these freaking
people in your family they're gonna know
your last name they're gonna have to
kill me they're gonna know your last
name what are you saying we're regular
people what is the matter with you why
are you saying that I understand but
they're going to know who you are and
how many people's lives you change your
son's gonna show the world what you're
all about you'll see I call my family my
sister and my brother-in-law coming out
guys I don't I don't talk like this I
had a paradigm shift
I went to sales meetings this is is this
Long Beach Convention Center 20 years
ago I went to a Tony Robbins seminar
here I was 21 years old
these are Paradigm Shift type of moments
but you have to receive it when this
thing ends at 7 30 tonight I don't know
what plans everybody got I'll tell you
what I'd be doing if I was at a place
like this especially with the [ __ ] show
of the market we got going on right now
I'm not going to the bar drinking I'm
gonna go get cards and network do all
that stuff boom straight away from
everybody business planning pen paper
let's go for hours
I'm gonna have a paradigm shift type of
a moment at this event I'm gonna change
my life what hard skills do I need what
character do I need to improve as a
human being what soft skills do I need
what do I need to do I'm going to do
something special in my life that's the
decision you got to be making FYI less
than five percent of you will do what I
just said
less than five percent of you will do
what I just said most of you are looking
forward to partying tonight
I went to an insurance conference one of
the main Executives says Pat why don't
you ever drink with everybody I said
drink for what
he says but you always have a drink but
you start with the same drink and at the
end of the night it's the same drink
with the same amount left
I said first I want to make everybody
feel comfortable I have a drink but I'm
not drinking why don't you drink
because if I drink
I'm loose I'm no longer learning I'm
talking
If I Stay still they're talking I'm
learning why would I drink
he says I never thought about it that
way before
you guys got to make a decision these
numbers I'm telling you these people are
not any more special than you they made
a flipping decision a long time ago
they made a very major decision a long
time ago and today your family your
peers people around you are relying on
you I went to this protesting right
before I'm going 120 miles an hour on
the freeway with people in the car
I want to run the Iranian Community I
don't like what's going on anymore it
bothers me I was born in Iran I'm made
in America I'm half Armenian half a
Syrian and I love America but I love
Iran
I got four kids I want to one day take
them there and show them these places
these things matter to me
you have to think about your heritage
you have to think about the sacrifices
your mom your dad made to bring you to
America you you owe it to them on what
they did for you
that has to get you to be thinking about
your dreams in a completely different
way this ain't about a Lambo and a
Ferrari and a Rolls-Royce and a 25
million dollar house they're saying
about that
this about today the world is looking
for leaders and what are you going to do
about it
that's what today's all about
so now these two things bottom one
reliable citizen I'm willing to bet a
hundred percent of your reliable
citizens you're good for Marketplace
you pay your bills you pay your taxes
you take care of your family I'm willing
to bet 99 of you guys are good citizens
or else you wouldn't be at an event like
this
the one above is impactful citizen it is
time for us to make a decision to become
an impactful citizen not just a reliable
citizen this is the part about a
paradigm shift I told you right up front
I was going to be straight up with you
you can have plenty of motivational
speakers it's not my style I'm going to
give it to you raw you'll like it great
you don't like it it's not my problem
you got to do something with this that's
how I like to be spoken to
I want somebody to tell me exactly what
the hell is going on and what do I need
to know and what do I need to do about
it that's all I want to hear from you
that's the message and I took so to wrap
it up here for you guys on this message
side you have to understand this part
guys I want to finish with this
never in my life have I been more
optimistic about the future and shit's
never been crazier than it is today
so weird
it has never been crazier than it is
today and I've been I've never been more
optimistic than I am today
the country we're living in living in
has always been known for developing
leaders
if you live in America you come to
America if you attend an event like
driven posted by Albert and sill who
they've been doing this year after year
after year after year after year for six
years Good Times bad times doesn't
matter they're going to put their events
together which by the way Make some
noise for preciatos for doing a great
job hosting these events
this entire event was put together
[Applause]
this entire event
in a greedy way you have to think about
it this way this entire event when I
would come to events I would say this
this entire event's been put together
for one person
I don't care if there's 10 000 people in
the Room 5 000 people in normal thousand
people or 100 people in the room this
entire event was put together for one
person and that's me
which means it's who
it's you you got to receive the message
you got to make that paradigm shift
and then 6 12 24 36 months 10 years 13
years 26 years later
we're going to be reading about your
story I'm going to sit there and say
look at these this guy talked about an
event he was at 2022 when the market was
going crazy he attended this event
called driven look at what this guy did
with his life good for freaking him good
for freaking her good for freaking that
husband and wife that made a decision to
do something big for themselves and then
you're gonna be proud of yourself
foreign